Das ist wirklich unglaublich und echt kein superlativ ist zu übertrieben um diesen erfolg zu feiern
ein forschungsteam hat es geschafft lichtteilchen photonen
Also, zu molekülen zu gruppieren und dabei festgestellt dass sie dann 10.000 mal langsamer als licht sind die lichtgeschwindigkeit
Ist damit nicht mehr
unabänderlich
und diese moleküle
interagieren miteinander wie materie
Das ist wirklich absolut und fachlich wird das laserschwert jetzt realität dazu. Jetzt alle facts in klicks um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
An dieser stelle nochmals vielen dank an die community ob whatsapp die sind wirklich total gut unterwegs und finden immer wieder den neuesten heißen scheiß
Und das heer ist wirklich der absolute
unglaubliche sensationelle und so weiter aber manche beschweren sich ja hier da sich immer wieder superlative
Verwende aber das ist wissenschaft ständig werden neue beulen ins universum
Getreten und es werden erkenntnisse gewonnen die wirklich unglaublich sind und das hier ist so etwas wirklich absolut
Unfassbares und zu ende gedacht könnte es wirklich, so etwas wie
laserschwerter ermöglichen ja bei denen jahr zwei laserstrahlen die massive schwerter wie materie aneinander schlagen
licht verhält sich dabei wie materie und genau das hat jetzt ein forschungsteam
gemacht photonen zu molekülen verbunden und die verhalten sich jetzt wie materie mit geringer masse
also, der reihe nach vor einigen jahren entdeckten forscher rund um mladic
vom mit massachusetts
dass photonen einen unmöglichen zustand annehmen können wird ein schwacher laserstrahl durch eine wolke
ultrakalte rubidium atome geschickt verbinden sich einige photonen in diesem medium
zu paaren zitat eine passende analogie wären die aus science fiction filmen bekannten laserschwerter wenn diese photonen miteinander interagieren
Schubsen sie sich und lenken einander ab die physik dahinter ist ähnlich dem was in den
lichtschwertern ablaufen müsste das sagt politik mit dieser erkenntnis gingen die forscher einen schritt weiter wenn zwei
moleküle mit lichtteilchen möglich sind warum gehen da nicht auch drei moleküle sie verbesserten den versuchsaufbau
verfeinerten vor allem die messtechnik und schickten nur sehr wenige photonen durch die rubidium wolke und jetzt passierte das
Absolut verblüffende die photonen traten nicht nur in zwei sondern auch in dreiergruppen aus der wolke
zitat das bedeutet dass die photonen in diesen dreier gruppen nicht nur jeweils
einzeln mit einem zweiten interagieren sondern dass sie alle drei miteinander wechselwirken so koautor
aditya
benkert ramani von der harvard university und bahn hatten sie einen zweiten unbekannten und
unmöglichen zustand von licht erzeugt und er ist wirklich ab
Frappierend jetzt reagierten die photonen so träge als hätten sie masse und ihre geschwindigkeit war
10.000 mal langsamer als normalerweise bei licht aber achtung damit ist natürlich
nicht die
Relativitätstheorie außer kraft gesetzt der aufwand ist so groß und diese teilchen
herzustellen in der natur passiert das so einfach nicht es gilt also weiter die lichtgeschwindigkeit
Ist konstanz raum und zeit müssen sich um sie herum kommen zurück zu unserem seltsamen teilchen diese dreier
moleküle entstehen wenn in der wolke wenn die photonen mit den rubidium atomen interagieren
das atom wird angeregt und bildet zusammen mit dem foto nein
polarion es ist ein
Quasi teilchen energetisch reagiert es wie ein foto nackt rum hybrid teilchen wenn jetzt zwei oder drei
photonen solche polar itans bilden dann findet eine wechselwirkung der atomaren bestandteile stadt übersetzt heißt das also
atome und photonen verbindung sich miteinander
Womit die photonen atomare eigenschaften übernehmen der hammer aber ist selbst wenn die photonen die wolke dann
verlassen haben also gar keine polare tanz mehr sind verhalten sich weiter so sind quasi mit
Atomaren eigenschaften geimpft was ließe sich nicht nur alles mit licht
Molekülen machen was könnte damit gebaut werden tatsächlich ist das eine total irre perspektive
gegenstände aus licht vielleicht sogar nicht schwerter und tipps dazu bilden sich abstoßen photonen ein regelmäßiges muster oder
passiert etwas ganz anderes also eine echte terra incognita
Also unbekanntes terrain das hier beschritten wird ja leute das ist wissenschaft hier wird die. Welt wirklich zum teil neu erschaffen
Und echt kein superlativ ist hier übertrieben wenn er als erstes neues zu den licht
molekülen und zu allen anderen themen erfahren wollt dann meldet euch hierbei whatsapp an dann erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen anderen vom neuesten video
Eben vorab garantiert ihr könnt dort direkt in der redaktion von klicks und mitmachen und mit themen vorschlagen oder andere vorschläge machen
Der direkte draht zu mir einfach hier draufklicken und natürlich nicht das abo mit
Genau der glocke vergessen hier geht es weiter mit dafür draufklicken schnellste kamera der welt lichtteilchen in
außergewöhnlicher formation ansonsten würde ich mal sagen bis dann
bleibt dran